pick up  this is gonna be a crazy day at least  there aren't Star Wars happening  peaceably resolved all the Star Wars  who is driving that kind of fun stuff  you're gonna be able to see and they're  looking to get the Gangrel down the  person adjuster but what the hell like  Christopher Walken  what the hell what the what the hell  excuse me why in hot fart so we invite  you now I'm sorry can you say that  sentence just one more time that's  really beautiful kid is that for me no  this is mine  mara so talk your bushwhack kind of  position hey want to call back  use this to collect the cover it's part  of the party mom's job and don't let the  guests won't let go  you